the thing is officers are having to make
very very quick decisions to choose
whatever force option is most
appropriate for the situation we don't
train our officers to kill we train them
to stop that person with what with the
force necessary to overcome overcome
their resistance but that's something
that needs to be made almost in a
split-second it does
let's kinds up it's very tough the first
one is going to be a simulated firearm
which simulates our standard issue
weapon which is a Glock 22 secondarily
we have handcuffs this is their wrist
yeah you would just push straight
forward
taser it operates and feels just like a
regular taser third option pepper spray
this is a training version it's uh the
green label it says training okay I've
actually sprayed myself with it next
option the baton this is a foam baton so
you can actually strike see if this will
work on you so you aim like this uh yes
we don't want in the movies they go like
they go like this um people who are
poorly trained do them Oh what if I
choose to you is my charm in my
diplomatic skill that's fun yeah yeah
okay but some people need to be fought
so just a couple ground rules okay once
I tell you go ahead that's a start of
the snare and do everything it's best
you can in terms of what you're gonna do
what what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do go ahead
what are you gonna do a cup what do they
know can't do nothin you can't do
nothing I can truly go on the crab you
gonna cry gonna do it what are you gonna
do put your hands up put your hands
behind your back
put your hands behind your back what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do do it
a baton okay and stop okay couple things
one you see them fighting that happens
all the time arguing you see him hit
this guy he drops fast guard which tells
you what that's a fairly significant use
of force yeah what was he saying do you
remember my god it's Oliver I know but
he was saying I'm gonna kill you he said
that to me several times is there a
perfect resolution to this the answer is
No
hey get back in the ball hey stop
lieutenant what the hell was that yeah
that was that was a situation that has
played numerous times on dashcam videos
all around the country I don't
understand so I mean this is so
untypical right but you put an officer
through this training and they're gonna
be really aggressive anytime they stop a
car the next time I pull someone over
I'm gonna reach for my gun but I
shouldn't because he is an anomaly I
don't need the exception not the rule
I well you're right but we have to train
for those exceptions as an officer then
I need to operate with the assumption
that everyone's a potential threat you
should always be prepared to defend your
life at any moment
your taillight is out hold it hold him
on it
go put your head on him put your hands
on the steering wheel he's got a gun
okay see you next to him okay tell him
start talking your partner yeah okay
well he's got a gun right next to him
cover him now okay
he's cuffed put the gun away that's it
that's it done how do you train officers
you know not to be scared I don't think
you could ever truly teach somebody not
to be scared but you can teach them to
be confident and that's the goal is to
provide the confidence that not not only
can they use their tools but they choose
the correct tools given the situation so
what is it actually okay for cops to
kill under US law there are two
circumstances the first is in defense of
life